in this episode we're going to build an
anonymous authorization service with
angular 4 and fire-based this feature
will allow user to start using your app
without going through the typical ooofff
sign end or email password registration
process this approach is also called
lazy registration or gradual engagement
it works by creating a session using
only the user ID if the user signs out
without updating more account details
they will be unable to log back in and
retrieve any data that they created at
this point it's assumed that you have
the angularfire to package installed and
bootstrapped in your application if not
good at the docs or check out this video
if starting from scratch generate the
office service I'm actually going to be
building upon the all service from my
previous the last tutorial so I
recommend checking out that video first
if you haven't already head over to your
firebase project and enable the
anonymous provider first make sure to
subscribe to the firebase off state in
the constructor then write a function to
login the user with the anonymous
provider and let's also add a typescript
getter to see if a user who's currently
logged in is anonymous or not this will
be useful when displaying content
specifically for anonymous users in the
template
now we can inject the service into our
components to login users and
automatically in this case we just bind
the function to the click event of any
button or length in the template when
the anonymous user decides to upgrade
you'll need to transfer the account data
to a new account or somehow link the two
accounts together the firebase Web API
supports account linking but in order to
do this you would need to bypass the
angularfire to package is an alternative
you can simply create a new account and
then transfer the users data to it
assuming your data is nested under a
user ID here's how you could map it to a
new account the function works by taking
a snapshot of the data nested under the
anonymous ID then it copies that data to
the new account after the user
successfully logs in with Google that's
it for an honest aw check out the full
article for more details and I'll see
you next time
[Music]